thank you for having us here in London
we're glad you're all here but you what
you came to here is the panel to tell
you where the economy is going in Europe
so I'm going to ask all of our panelists
to please come up and be seated and then
I'll introduce them whether they're up
at the podium so come on up please
next to me here is Ross Algren is the
Tempur graduate from 1988 is general
partner and founder of crios Capital
Keith Cornell is a downer sorry Keith
Keith Cornell is the Tempur graduate
also from 1980 chairman of pro-lite we
have Devorah bolas down on the far end
Devore is a Heinz graduate 1999 correct
and the Devore is partner of fidelity
growth partners Alex canister CIT grad
from 1980 chairman of Pamplona Capital
Management and Karen Wilson in the
middle there between all the guys
MCS math major 1986 founder of GV
partners and also consultant for
structural policy division of the
science technology and Industry
Directorate of the OECD so please help
me in welcoming
I'm going to start a question off with
the with Ross when you look at the
global economy now Ross things you know
we're no longer in crisis mode so to
speak well we certainly do still face
headwinds and there's a long way for us
to go before we really feel comfortable
that we're in a true recovery now from
your perspective in your point of view
what's the current economic situation as
you see it here in Europe and there are
other positive signs or specific areas
within Europe that are doing
particularly well first of all I'm not
an economist or an academic I moved to
Europe about 20 years ago so it's a
probably an interesting perspective
being an American listening every time
you go back home to how Europe is dead
the euros falling apart France is an
outdoor museum etc and I think you have
to get being a venture capitalist you're
you're by nature naively optimistic so
you kind of have to take the the broad
brush and look a little bit under the
hood and I do think that there are
particular areas within Europe that are
doing well there's geographies the
Berlin the Tel Aviv's the london's of
stock homes that are creating Europe in
general probably when I started the
business 15 years ago didn't have the
infrastructure that from a venture
capitalist either that that America did
you didn't have a real reliable and
stable infrastructure of serial
entrepreneurs very good management teams
early-stage venture capital and its
people like Keith down there and other
people that have raised the game over
the last 15 years to where we now see
serial entrepreneurs coming back we we
start to see some of these things
happening we're starting to see more and
more long term venture capital like our
firm is on its fourth fund so there's a
bit of an ecosystem that's developing
along those lines I think you also have
a unique sort of blend in Europe not
only time zones for a financial market
point of view but from a venture point
of view from M&A activity
it's a it's a much more natural home for
Middle Eastern money or Russian money
there were a lot of other money coming
here for M&A we were just approached by
one of our investors from Silicon Valley
who's helping a Chinese a large
conglomerate do M&A in Europe there's
barriers to entry for the Chinese to do
to work in the u.s. there aren't
prevalent in Europe so there's those
areas and I think we're always going to
follow the u.s. in terms of our
broadband penetration and things like
that so the whole online you know
offline to online sort of thing is
accelerating very rapidly Europe has
always been probably better at mobile
devices than America so it really plays
into the hands here of having a single
standard for all of Europe so we don't
tend to go from New York to New Jersey
and drop phones we can go country to
country and it still works and that
bodes well for the future where every
device is mobile thank you very much
Alex so there's a lot of attention paid
to the problems within Europe in the
euro zone during this sort of economic
crisis in Sony in your view is what is
it that's unique about Europe relative
to say the US as an example and is it
the case that Europe is facing deeper
problems or is that somewhat of a
misconception well it's a bit of a
question on economics as well right and
they say what's the difference between
economists and astrologists and the
answer is astrologist get guess right
sometimes so it's tough to to really say
what's ahead I mean the obvious
difference between the problems in
Europe and in the u.s. is the European
Union and the eurozone in particular is
a monetary union and it's very tricky to
maintain a monetary union without a
fiscal union and without a social Union
Union of social policies so
in the US where the fiscal the social
policies are the same you've got
retirement age you've got work week
you've got labor laws federal laws
prevalent and also you have this central
bank and the Ministry of Finance where
the borrowing and the money printing
machines are somewhat linked in Europe
the problem you have is you got
countries with their own budgets and
they borrow money separately but they
can't print it separately they have to
go to ECB for the printing press and
then the Germans say you know why should
we support funding Greeks or French when
their work week is half of ours and
their retirement age is 20% less and so
on so it creates a lot of tensions
because the union is not complete having
said that the fundamental problem that
they're all facing you know European
countries of the u.s. is budget deficits
I think US budget deficit is the same as
if not worse than many European
countries debt level is the same if not
worse but because US is bigger it's got
let's say on balance more innovation and
it's got more importantly and
unrestricted especially in the current
administration printing press it can get
over the hurdles and make things look
like they're better when fundamentally
they're not really that much better so
in the short term I would say they're
better in the long term the problems
that Europe is having have become more
acute and when the problems are more
acute they let's say require more
attention and because of that there's
maybe some probability of them getting
fixed I don't see anything happening in
the u.s. that will fix the problems so
longer-term I'm not sure I'm much more
optimistic about the US and Europe
they just have different kinds of
problems but of similar nature the one
thing about the US that people
oftentimes don't factor in is we focus
on the federal deficit and federal debt
but there's plenty of deficit in debt at
the state level as well and if you fold
a daddy and things do look much worse
than just looking at the federal yeah
and if you look at the public debt which
is the government of what seventy-five
percent of GDP but then you had the
state that you had the Social Security
and all the other sort of off-balance
sheet numbers you get well over a
hundred percent of GDP and the budget
deficit is writing and we'll take
percent of GDP so fundamental problems
are still there and there's no real
movement to cut the entitlements well in
Europe in many places there is already
because of the crisis thank you Karen so
the Carnegie Mellon likes to sort of
how'd itself is being a place for
innovation and entrepreneurship and
technology innovation in particular so
and small business and startup companies
in general do provide significant growth
in the US if you look at Europe to what
extent do startups and entrepreneurship
factored into the growth story for
Europe I mean entrepreneurship is has
never been more important in Europe than
it is today and Europe needs new sources
of growth many countries around the
world need but certainly a quest sure up
and traditionally Europe has relied upon
large companies it varies of course
across countries in Europe but on large
companies and also on SMEs
but the problem is the majority of SMEs
I've seen numbers that show about 60
percent of SMEs don't want to grow their
small businesses their restaurants their
mom-and-pop shops what Europe needs or
more high-growth firms its high-growth
firms we've seen from research that
we've done at the OECD and other
academic research has been done by many
people in the US and in Europe in other
parts of the world that is these young
innovative firms that create jobs and
economic growth and that's what Europe
needs and that's what we're really
missing the culture is changing this you
mentioned things are improving in the
last five to ten years but we still have
a long way to go I think there are a
number of things that need to be done in
Europe first of all you mentioned some
of the regulatory sort of barriers
across Europe there are different rules
in different European countries so it's
hard for these high-growth firms to grow
across Europe because there are barriers
to doing business across borders so
that's one issue another issue of course
is finance with the recent financial
crisis many banks don't want to loan to
startups many venture capital firms at
least here in Europe have been reluctant
to invest it to seed in early-stage
they're out at the later stage there's
been a gap in the seed in early-stage
financing angel investors are starting
to step up to the plate we've done some
work on that at the OECD they're playing
a very important role here in Europe and
many other countries around the world
but there's still a gap in fact we can
see in the numbers that venture capital
financing in Europe is one-fourth what
it is in the US but what's even more
alarming is that there are many more
deals in Europe but there's much smaller
so it just shows the fragmentation we're
not giving we're giving a lot of money
to many companies but we're not giving
enough for them to really grow and get
Beyond Borders and be successful and be
those big companies like we see in the
US so there's a lot of work to be done
there unfortunately in Europe the policy
makers like to come in and they want to
help fix the problem European
policymakers like to throw money at the
problem and I think that only makes it
worse in some ways the public sector can
play an important role by being a
catalyst but they have to be a catalyst
for getting private investors in and the
problem is the many cases they crowd out
private investors so there needs to be a
balance of you know what is the role of
see how can they encourage private
investors to come in how can they
address market failures but then get out
once the market is working well again
and the last point I would say is that
culture is very important and it is
changing but in Europe there's still a
very strong fear of failure many people
don't want to take a risk they don't
want to go and try a startup because if
they fail they'll never get a job again
and and so they they don't want to try
whereas in the u.s. if you start a
company and you fail it's almost like a
badge of honor and you start again and
and everyone's going to see a chance but
but they are both perceived and real
barriers even including bankruptcy rules
in different countries in Europe so that
really needs to be addressed but to
address culture to change culture it's
really a long-term thing and I think
that's where schools and universities
play a very important role so I think
integrating entrepreneurship into the
curriculum is really really important
exposing students to it having to
realize that it's a career option for
them many students in Europe don't think
about that they want to work in them in
the public sector so I think that
entrepreneurship education is very very
important and building that ecosystem
building links between universities and
business and I think you said earlier
for the talk that 40% of the companies
in the Pittsburgh area Pennsylvania
students being there's some connection
to Carnegie Mellon okay it's that
ecosystem Carnegie Mellon has been
reaching out and working with the
community and we need to see more of
that with the universities in Europe
okay great excellent Keith
so Karen just mentioned venture capital
and about it being and I think the
fourth of what it what it is in in the
u.s. in the u.s. it's a really important
source of funding for for young startup
types of companies how do you see the
state of venture capital here in Europe
and how does it compare to the US you
know Bob I am I actually came into this
talk with a couple of points to make and
I was fairly negative and pessimistic I
was trying to figure out where Ross got
the kool-aid because he was pretty
upbeat on that
so I tested my messages on a venture
capitalist in the audience I'm not gonna
give him any billing because he's never
given me money but he said we'll keep
there's huge structural problems and all
those structural problems have been
covered the first one is if you look at
the same population of the US and Europe
it's not a common market so all the
ventures that I work in have global
businesses they don't want to be local
the second thing which Karen mention a
little bit is all about serial
entrepreneurs we don't have garage
startups that have had garage startups
we don't have entrepreneurs that go home
and teach their kids to be entrepreneurs
and I want to be an entrepreneur when I
grew up we have a failure mentality as
well so we don't have this serial nature
of it's in the blood the third thing is
if you ask an entrepreneur in the UK
what do they want to do they want to get
their exit and then they want to move
the south of France and retire and so
you're looking at this scenario where I
just did an exit in Sweden the options
the black Scholes model had to be paid
for by the employees when they got
granted the options so they had to put
after-tax money in to buy an option we
did it down round those options are now
worthless so they put in their after-tax
money and are no longer owners we
finally do an exit and if you actually
look at how much they got out of the
exit it was about 20 percent of what the
actual funding to that exit to their
pocket was it was it was awful so we
have structural problems now why am i
pessimistic about venture capital Europe
first off what's happened is it's been a
feast and famine all the institutions
jumped in in the late 90s all those
funds were invested from 99 to 2002 they
didn't do very well then we got into
2005 we had another bit of a boom
everybody started jumping in again guess
what we had 2008 so what's happened is
we've had lousy returns in venture
capital number one um
what's also happened because of that the
timing and what's going on is a venture
capital fund usually raises for seven
year life and it takes them a couple
years to invest what's happened is exits
used to take
as in liquidity events used to take
somewhere in the three-year kind of
number two plus two three in Europe in
the 2000s that's gone now to almost
eight so you have exits taking you know
much much longer if you look a deal flow
our deal flow is in fact a quarter to
the u.s. there were about six point 1
billion dollars worth of deals done last
year it was just over a thousand that
could cross Europe that is the lowest
number since 2000 in terms of actual
deals being done and then the final
reason why I'm pessimistic is because of
the bad returns because the less deals
what's occurred is there's less seed
money and because there's less seed
money you get less entrepreneurs
lasondra business startups and so what's
happened is there's been this shift of
the money to more what I'll call
emerging growth or kind of be around and
see around when there's a little bit
less risk you can see the horizon little
bit better so the venture capitals serve
a bit scary so I'm you know I'm a user
of venture capital but I'm pretty
pessimistic on the state of Europe right
now and venture capital let me follow up
just briefly there do you see money for
venture capital money coming from the
u.s. to Europe
yes absolutely in fact I was on Sand
Hill two weeks ago with my tin cup
looking for money so um but the US has
had its own problems the US and 2007
raised 40 billion dollars in the VC
funds last year it was 20 billion it's
gone from 40 to 20 in five years we're
about six billion in Europe plus or
minus so the US has its own problems but
the u.s. is getting a lot smarter on
focusing those funds and they will talk
to a European company when I tried to
raise funds in 2005 all of them would
talk to me
none of them would give me money none of
them wanted to come to Europe without
having an office they're starting to
change that now Devore so as you see
Europe do you see any particular areas
of for there's likely be some
significant growth and and maybe if you
could focus possibly on the technology
area is that what role does that play in
the growth story for Europe
well first I would say we should just
ketchup off the dish panel I'm a venture
capitalist and we focused 100% on
investing in technology companies so I
don't know I live in a very different
Europe and maybe it's my us education
but I kind of bring that perspective and
I think that one of the key issues that
people make is that they forget that
history is not indicative of future and
future returns and last decade or so I
think in technology in Europe has been
pretty brutal and a lot of the stories
and a lot of the points that people have
made I think I could not agree with more
but I do think things are changing and
they're changing all across the
continent they're changing for people
who maybe were best of the best and had
chances to you know go into banking or
hedge funds and those people are now
considering real jobs and they're
realizing that you know building
something actually is is more rewarding
than you know working in a company just
for the salary statistics show actually
the Entrepreneurship pace and that
entrepreneurship for me taking some
qualification make more money in the
lifetime but I really want to focus on
the data that would make me feel you
know confident I looked at our portfolio
of companies that we invested since 2010
that are new hundred million pound fund
the lowest growth annual growth is 65
percent year over year we invest in
companies and software internet
e-commerce and in games and why is that
80% of the internet use is outside of
the US today you know it's it's not any
more about Silicon Valley clearly
Silicon Valley is the key but you know
we see companies spring and being built
doing our companies all around you
Spotify in the Nordics zalando in
Germany Wonga here in the UK and the
list goes on and on even the short ten
years some of those companies did not
exist so this is sort of the new breed
of companies and just to give you for
example gaming you know people have gone
back and forth about Zynga and whether
it's a great company or not recently
last week there was an article about
King calm and you at European company
has just eclipsed Zynga as the largest
social gaming company company based here
in the UK supercell business in the
Nordics is now the largest iPhone game
developer so these are the companies and
entrepreneurs who don't have that
recollection of what it was like 10 last
10 years or 15 years and all those guys
don't know you know maybe that they
shouldn't be as ambitious as the US
counterparts retail three point four
trillion euro industry here in Europe
alone and people forget that you know
some of the largest global brands are
European brands hmm you know close to
hundred billion our company is a
European business IKEA Zara Inditex Alby
so all these companies again are
homegrown European businesses and what
we're seeing now with this offline to
online move we're seeing the same Giants
being built on the on the online side so
the lambda which is rumored to go public
at multi billion dollar valuation a
sauce which is already a multi-billion
dollar company here in the UK you know
we see these these industries growing a
double-digit percents even here in
Europe and I think next ten years is
gonna be different from the last ten
years and that's why I'm bullish okay
great thank you I want you to think
about some questions I'm going to ask
one last question and leave it open to
anybody to answer but think of some
questions that you'd want to ask the
panel regulation taxation what what is
the situation here in Europe it's a big
deal
the US now talking about how the tax
burden should be who should bear the tax
burden how does that affect
entrepreneurship here in Europe
how does regulation affect that any
thoughts on that and and and then I know
Karen answered the question directly but
what role does government play in
general and maybe universities what role
can they have in this process so I guess
since I live in France question yeah you
know I there needs to be an incentive
for people to go and take a risk to
start a company and to try to build a
successful with me and if you put in
place taxes of 75 percent on people who
are successful or if you increase as
France tried to do but they got there
was too much pushback capital gains
taxes from thirty six percent one of the
highest I think in any European country
they wanted to increase it to sixty
percent you know what kind of incentive
why would anyone start a company you
know why go is it's not that
entrepreneurs are not necessarily
starting companies for the money
they're doing it for many many reasons
but obviously there needs to be some
reward for taking the risk and putting
in all the hard work and so you know I
think that in particular France you know
they talk about growth but if you want
to have growth you can't penalize people
for succeeding and growing firms and
growing the economy high tax is
definitely bad especially you know for
those who are not in real industries but
you know I look at the Nordics right and
they have very high tax rates but they
have a lot of innovation and a lot of
startups so I'm not sure there's a
direct there's a direct correlation I
think in France maybe they all want to
move to south of France so I don't know
that's it maybe because that cultural
issue yeah yeah it's a culture issue but
in the Nordics the tax rates are
outrageous and there's a lot of
innovation
out of there there's a lot of people are
falling in love it right now no in the
UK a lot of entrepreneurs moving to the
UK the UK is attempting to do some work
around enterprise schemes and around
creating better taxation vehicles or
angels to want to invest they're not
quite there yet but they are they are
moving in that in that direction I can't
comment on it on anywhere else
great ok do we have questions from the
audience anybody want to ask our
panelists a question yes what is how do
you think the UK and the rest of Europe
will be impacted if the UK were to leave
the European Union based on David
Cameron's announcement well I'll take a
very quick cut out at only because I was
in Scotland this weekend and I keep
wondering about the devolution of
Scotland you know the UK I think is the
third largest provider of funds into the
EU and I think separating from the U and
not having those funds go into the U I
think will create some amount of issues
because we're in that giver of funds
rather than a net user I'm sort of
baffled by it because if you went back a
year ago we'd be talking about oh the
figs gonna fall apart and what's gonna
happen to to that whole scenario and now
we're thinking about is vide UK going to
leave it's funny to be sitting on this
island for 20 years and talk about the
UK exiting vu
I think it's bluster but again I'm not
in the flow I just think it's
positioning to to try to get the the
Tories to move to a different stage but
that's a personal feeling
I'll look questions but way in the back
I'm gonna make it difficult for you to
get the microphone over there um
something near and dear to my heart
having just moved from the United States
to Europe how do you person being a job
seeker how do you look at a Europe in
terms of the jobless recovery is it do
you think it's the same as in the US or
is it a little bit different in dynamics
I live in Spain and under 25s I don't
know how under 25s I think the
employment unemployment rates over 55%
so it's it's insane under under over
2000 over 25 I think it's 25 percent so
in in Germany it's probably low single
digits so it's like the difference
between Alabama New York California it's
a there's a big diversity you know it's
it's very different regionally and and
by country but definitely I would say
the problems in Europe are much more
acute than in the u.s. the banks here
for example are way behind the US banks
and recovery and in willingness to lend
and how they approach their bed debts
and dealing with it and so on so I think
in the u.s. you have a number of areas
for example one area where regulation
plays an important role is innovation
and energy the shale gas shale oil in
the u.s. is just a huge booming market
creating thousands probably hundreds of
thousands of jobs in the in Europe all
the regulations and all the different
barrettes looking at it analyzing it
looking at popular support it's not
moving anywhere even though their
reserves are here just just as well so I
think Europe or who might slower to
recover and therefore much slower and
job creation I've got one comment for
you as a jobseeker since I'm an
unemployed CEO right now Karen brought
it up in terms of failures talk about
your successes talk about what you've
done
talk about
actual change and get out there if
you're aggressive you can find jobs
there's no question but don't talk about
failures because it's just not something
that's culturally positive in terms of
getting a job and I've taken a few
businesses to bankruptcy so I try to
avoid this Ross I forgot to tell you
about those will say you know what's
really puzzling for me is that as Ross
said you know you have countries with
very low unemployment and then you have
countries very high unemployment in the
u.s. maybe it's also because of the
single language people migrated and here
we have we actually have some companies
we looked at in in Spain and despite the
fact that they're trying to hire like
crazy you know there is still a city you
know huge number of unemployed people
and yet they cannot hire right people so
even within a single country not just
maybe the Spaniards don't speak German
so you know they don't want to move to
front foot it's somehow I think this
this cultural piece which we need to
work on because we need to sort of
almost reeducate people about that you
know the world is changing in terms of
you can't just be sitting and expecting
a job to be available to you you need to
read you know you need to retrain you
need to sort of potentially change
cities you need to potentially learn in
your language and given the fact that we
have an aging population it's it's kind
of a at least the young people a need to
sort of get on with it so to speak and
learn that we live in a global world and
you know it might be the company in the
Nordics that is recruiting and Spanish
you just apply just like any other one
else Carrie do you have something I was
gonna say something about labor mobility
so it was a similar issue yeah the one
business is doing well in the u.s. is
moving vans yeah exactly
other questions here yeah yes
I have a little bit of experience here
because I've just joined a company
polite which has quite a quite an
extensive patent portfolio and one of
the questions we've been asking
ourselves it's at the board level is is
there the ability for others to block us
I'm my last company which was in Wi-Fi
chips has actually had a number of
blocking patent suits from some court in
East Texas that loves to do this stuff
I've been very difficult so as an
entrepreneur we think about how do we
get European patents we actually budget
them we had a discussion today at the
board we had three scenarios do we go
for one patent two patents or four
patents this year and we literally
costed out what it would what it would
do and why we would do it so we're we're
trying to build companies that have
protection around them and we're hoping
that we don't get into this era is that
you're talking about of the trolling
because you hope your idea is good
enough fast enough and you get it to the
market and get it in there not a great
answer to your question but it's certain
we talked about at the board level all
the time and the technology side it's
it's pretty important and we have had
companies that have won against the
giants in the u.s. that have been fringe
especially in mobile things that the
Europeans did very well
quickly but the process I'd it's it's
mainly execution the ideas in DA's a lot
of that stuff and in most ecommerce
business that's just who executes better
thank you good question
others yes we have a lot of stories
recently particularly the UK around
international companies delivering
economic value for only a very few so
for example Amazon Starbucks Facebook
how do you think we can make you know
companies the venture the the venture
capital supportive companies even a
company's scale sustainable job creation
for for a whole nation not just for a
select few
those of you in DC I mean I would love
to just understand you know what does it
mean select view in addition to you know
some of these companies employing tens
of thousands of people I think the
question of the ecosystem is you know
one that I always you know believe that
the first time you you know or as soon
as we see ten billion dollar companies
in our ecosystem you will see huge
amount of kind of positive externality
in the whole community you know people
who were our management teams of these
companies will go on and set up new
companies hire people but I think that
if if the point is that they're kind of
haves and have-nots in the knowledge
economy I mean I think that is probably
I would definitely agree with that which
is that the world is catering towards I
mean we were talking about the
importance of innovation and how much
even the Sienese
continues to continue to focus on it I
think it's critical for every single
person to really be focused on
developing a unique set of knowledge
skills
another democratic good so to speak that
intrapreneurs create yeah so I think the
solution is education there was a really
nice sketch book that was stunned by the
Kauffman Foundation last year about this
point about the impact that these
high-growth firms have whether they're
venture capital back or angel back door
family and friends backed but in terms
of all the spillover effects that they
have and the jobs that they're creating
in the economic growth and the
opportunity they're giving to many
people not just to employees but also to
consumers who then have these products
that they can use and then are learning
so I mean there are many it's it's
highly recommended they now have done
many of them but it was the first one
they did and it was really really good
but you know we don't always see all of
these spillover effects that these
high-growth firms have but they impact a
lot of people in in many positive ways
so it's not just a select few that are
benefiting and hello so so I work for
eBay and we saw there are two big
opportunities one year so sure another
is mobile devices and I just arrived you
London yesterday and saw a lot of people
using their mobile devices during
walking so I just think that do you
think in Europe there's opportunities
because we are talking about innovation
and entrepreneurship so I just wonder -
do you see any opportunities for these
two specific region one social ones
mobile device Thanks
opportunities here for social and both
of for social and mobile devices
absolutely
as I said before I think from the early
days of GSM I think Europe got to write
one standard across tall and it exploded
with innovation with everything that was
around that and I think now it's it's
the same thing I think it's happening
globally I think there's probably it's
at some point it's gonna surpass the
amount of search and product everything
that's at the bottom the internet will
be more on local devices with tablets or
phones or or whatever but that the
phones give unique capability to do
location-based services and and other
things I mean it's it's fascinating
what's going on with it right now for me
I mean just one thing that really gets
me excited is these technologies are
complete equalizers you know when we if
you look at the number of applications
that are submitted for the the App Store
or you know how easy it is to write an
application for Facebook it doesn't
really matter you know who you are or
where you sit it is absolutely
democratic in the sense that you can
submit your application to an app store
or to Apple they'll almost democratic
you could argue with Apple being the
dictator in some ways but still you can
submit an application and if people want
to use it around the world
you will get the uptake and we're
actually seeing now Chinese companies
like $0.10 releasing you know we chat
applications in the broader world
because they're they want to be global
and they don't have it they don't have
to set up offices they don't have to
hire people on the ground they can
literally release an application from
from from Shanghai and be global
overnight so I think I think this is
sort of one of those opportunities where
people can stop talking about well I
come from you know Croatia which is
where I come from and it's impossible
actually there are people from Croatia
who have made great companies using
these technologies in the last five
years thank you in the last question in
the back
last question so I'll make it rather
broad so I'm a scientist so for me
innovation you know it's anonymous with
science and the other way around being a
scientist and also being an American who
has worked for both an American National
Lab but also for two European ones in
Germany and CERN the global based in
Switzerland friend that I see is that in
the u.s. there is budgetary issues and
so on and most of it is there other
public funding you know funding coming
from governments and so on for science
and for innovation in science now it
seems that there's not much of a private
component when it comes to some of these
scientific endeavors and it seems to be
more of a one-way street meaning you
know some of these ideas or technologies
developed in lab then somehow he comes
back in the industry but not the other
way around especially you know the way
these labs are run these are huge
they're like corporations this is 1,000
plus you know lots of PhD scientists and
so on
but they're not the managers in these
labs whatever you can call them don't
really have as much management
experience they're scientists themselves
who may have some talents and management
not all of them do that and it doesn't
seem that you know you don't meet as
many MBAs or people who have been
trained in management in these fields so
yes maybe they're not interested in it
or maybe they just don't have exposure
or credentials so it's probably more
than one question nice fellow MTS Brett
and Pamela so this is not just everyone
else these are my questions let me try
let me try and take a stab at that
myself Carnegie Mellon is unique in in
the sense that our MBAs which they're
learning the business skills to allow
many of these new technologies and
innovations to be taken
commercialised many of them have science
and engineering backgrounds already when
they come into the MBA program and
they're well they're they're very well
aware of what it what's what's happening
and what it takes to be an innovator or
a scientist an engineer so I may see
things a little bit differently than
other MBA programs would see them but
our students interact in programs with
faculty and students from all over
campus and they do so in an
interdisciplinary way so I don't on the
CMU campus I see that interaction taking
place where MBAs are working with
engineers are working with designers are
working with computer scientists all
over campus and it happens naturally on
Carnegie Mellon's campus I can't speak
to any other University because I've
never been on any other University
campus other than the one I graduated
from but what happens at Carnegie Mellon
scam is just very unique in that sense I
don't know if that helps answer your
question at all but I mean again our I
think our MBAs are well positioned to
interact with scientists and engineers
on innovative products in the u.s. some
schools and in Carnegie Mellon and other
leading schools have really integrated
entrepreneurship requests to the
curriculum which is great and really
important but in Europe there's still a
big segmentation between engineering
schools and the design schools in the
business schools it's starting to change
but it really does need to change
because many of these entrepreneurs
these high-growth entrepreneurs they
come from science engineering medicine
design they they don't often come from
the business schools and so there needs
to be this integration across where the
business school students are taking
classes with the others and it's
happening now
at Carnegie Mellon I think there's a
culture there but in Europe there's not
that culture and so it's really
important to change that there is some
movement in fact in Finland three
universities actually merged together
the Helsinki School of Economics the
Technical University in the design
school and they became one of Shapiro
University the Technical University of
Munich as well the president had a goal
of becoming an entrepreneurial
University and they're reaching out to
other universities in the Munich area so
it is starting to change but it doesn't
come naturally so I think Carnegie
Mellon was really lucky that it has this
sort of culture but it's really
important for entrepreneurship that it
is integrated and and that there is a
ecosystem built around the university as
well like Carnegie Mellon is also done
all right well thank you very much we
want to thank you all I want to thank
Alex Caron teeth and Devore thank you
very much for participating this evening
please